[Music]
about five years ago Google started this
interesting experiment they wanted to
figure out how to build the perfect team
and so what they did is they started
collecting huge amounts of data about
all the teams within Google and their
initial hypothesis was you can make
teams better by putting the right people
together right if you have some
introverts and some extroverts or maybe
you have on people who are friends away
from the conference room or or maybe you
need strong leaders and followers but
who you put together they figured is the
way to build the perfect team that's
that's the thing you want to control so
they collected all their data they spent
millions of dollars and years looking at
this stuff and they couldn't find any
correlation between who was on a team
and whether that team was effective or
not so they decided to start looking at
this question a completely different way
they started focusing instead of who is
on the team they started looking at how
the team interacts we've all felt this
before that maybe away from a team
setting where we're really outgoing but
then when we sit down we kind of are
more sedate because that's how the team
behaves or maybe there's a group norm
that it's okay for people to interrupt
each other or maybe it's the alternative
that the group norm is that everyone
takes turns talking or you stay on the
agenda or you start the meeting by
gossiping groups develop these unwritten
rules and that's how they function and
it turns out those group norms that was
the thing that determined whether a team
was successful or not in particular
there were two norms that seemed to have
a huge influence on whether a team could
work together and really become
productive the first was what's known as
equality and conversational turn-taking
what this basically means is does
everyone at the table get a chance to
speak up
we've all been in team meetings where
half the table is quiet right maybe some
expert is in the room and and when a
question comes up they just talk for 10
or 15 minutes and they tell everyone
what they ought to do that might be
really efficient but that's terrible for
a team the best teams
turns out our ones where everyone at the
table regardless of whether they're they
know what they're talking about or not
feels like they have an opportunity to
make their voice heard the second norm
the second behavior that makes groups
more effective is what's known as high
social sensitivity essentially can I
pick up on how you're thinking and
feeling based on nonverbal cues if
you've got your arms crossed do I say to
you hey Jim it looks like you're kind of
like I'm not super into this idea can
you tell us about that or if you look
super enthusiastic do I say Susan you
look really like you like this idea like
tell me what what you think we should do
next
the way that we encourage equality and
conversational turn-taking in high
social sensitivity is sometimes by doing
these things like gossiping with each
other or allowing someone to talk even
if maybe they're not an expert on a
topic or getting to know each other in a
way that if someone takes the
conversation off agenda we say hey I
understand that this is important to you
go with it for a little while in other
words the teens that at a glance look
most productive oftentimes aren't but if
you can create this conversational
turn-taking
equality of voices if you can convince
people to really listen to each other by
being sensitive to the nonverbal cues
were giving off then you create
psychological safety and psychological
safety is the single greatest
determinant and whether a team comes
together or whether it falls apart one
of my favorite examples of psychological
safety and a team really commenting
coming together is the early days of
Saturday alive so when you think about
it Saturday Night Live never should have
worked right you have a bunch of
comedians who are kind of misanthropes
to begin with and they're all kind of
ego maniacs and yet for some reason when
Lorne Michaels put them in a room
together everyone was willing to kind of
get along they they were willing to put
aside their ego and create this amazing
show together not only an amazing show
but a show that was put together under
these incredible time pressures right
they have a week to put together a live
show and when I talked to the early
writers and performers on Saturday Night
Live
they ask them away that's happened all
of them said the same thing because of
Lauren Michaels so Lauren Michaels has
this very unique way of running meetings
he sits down and the meeting starts and
what he'll do is he'll make everyone go
around the table and say something and
if someone hasn't spoken up in a little
while
Lauren Michaels will actually stop the
meeting and he'll say Suzy I noticed
that you haven't chimed in like what are
you thinking about right now and if
somebody looks upset if an actor looks
like he's having a bad day or a writer
sort of seems like they're pissed off
Lauren Michaels will get and stop the
meeting and he'll actually take that
person out of the room and he'll say
look it looks like something's going on
that's bugging you like let's talk about
it what what's happening in your life
now what's crazy about this is that this
actually makes meetings kind of go on
forever and Lorne Michaels is like known
for being productive right he's known
for this person who creates these
amazing shows and and is doing like 12
things at any given time but the way he
runs meetings is that he makes sure
everyone in the room has something to
say and if you look like you're thinking
something and not verbalizing it he
makes you verbalize it or he takes you
aside and he says what's going on with
you like why why are you upset or or are
you happy what Lauren Michaels does is
he creates psychological safety he's
like a master of creating psychological
safety and as a result he's able to take
all these huge outsized egos and all
these actors and writers who are
comedians and so almost by their very
nature they hate other people and he's
able to bring them all together into
this cauldron of pressure of creating a
live television show in a week and it
all works out but it's because he
creates an environment that feels safe
where everyone feels like they can speak
up and they feel like everyone else is
genuinely listening to them because
they're sensitive to all the cues that
there's something
[Music]